dropping a nuclear bomb inside
a hurricane drop a nuclear bomb on them
the president suggested bombing a
hurricane on multiple occasions
briefers reportedly told the president
we'll look into that
believe it or not president donald trump
isn't the first person to suggest we
nuke a hurricane
back in the 50s a meteorologist named
jack reed
introduced the idea as a way to prevent
hurricanes from reaching the coast
high and low pressure areas are recorded
hourly at each station
and people have been asking why we don't
nuke hurricanes
ever since in fact the national oceanic
and atmospheric administration has been
asked
this question so much it has a
web page dedicated to answering just
that
so if you set off a nuclear weapon in a
hurricane not only will you still have a
hurricane
now you have a radioactive hurricane so
that's that's not a positive development
for perspective a hurricane can generate
the same amount of energy throughout its
lifetime as 10
000 nuclear bombs and the physical size
of a hurricane is a major issue as well
hurricane irma measured 420 miles across
that's 70 times as large as the blast
zone for little boy
the nuclear bomb dropped over hiroshima
so detonating an atomic bomb inside a
hurricane is sort of like poking a rhino
with a stick
and expecting it to just get out of your
way it's not going to happen
oh and then there's the issue of highly
radioactive nuclear fallout
best case scenario is that it rains out
very quickly
and so the area that you set the weapon
off
becomes highly radioactive and
contaminated that's your best case
scenario
a more worst case scenario is what if
that somehow stays in
the hurricane and moves as the hurricane
say makes landfall
in a worst case scenario winds from the
hurricane would quickly distribute the
radiation throughout the entire storm
basically turning it from a massive
storm with wind and rain
into a massive storm with radioactive
wind
and rain that's 10 times larger and
millions of times more powerful than any
nuclear bomb
in history not to mention hurricanes
move
fast in 2012 hurricane sandy traveled
over 2
000 miles from the caribbean sea up the
u.s
east coast in just 10 days and we know
from
past experience what nuclear fallout
does to an ocean and people nearby
in 1954 the united states set off a very
large thermonuclear weapon in the
marshall islands
and it contaminated a lot of fish in the
area
japan ended up having a moratorium on
fish consumption for some time
as a result of this and you could detect
the radioactivity in fish for
for thousands of miles plus scientists
estimated that 55 percent of all cancers
in those living closest to the bomb site
might be attributed to the bomb's
nuclear fallout
so if we had nuked say hurricane sandy
not only would there have been the 65
billion dollars in damage repair
but who knows how much more it would
have cost in the additional damage to
fishing industries
healthcare and even the simplest things
you might not think about
because you can't just rebuild the house
now you've also got to remove
you know several inches of topsoil and
destroy the
original material and rebuild from
scratch if you want people to be able to
live there
without increasing the cancer wounds
suffice it to say
nuking a hurricane as noah puts it is
not a good idea it's less of a sort of
doomsday scenario as it is just a like
really bad
idea no benefit scenario